blue food coloring can be oxidized by
household bleach which contains
hypochlorite household bleach will
usually consume sodium hypochlorite to
form colorless products as represented
by the equation above so this is the
food coloring reacts with the
hypochlorite produces a colorless
product a student uses a
spectrophotometer set at wavelength of
635 nanometers to study the absorbance
of the food coloring over time during
the bleaching process so since we're
talking about blue food coloring i'm
guessing that this is a wavelength of
light that is blue
since that's going to be optimally
absorbed by blue food coloring
in the study bleach is present in large
excess so the concentration of
hypochlorite is essentially constant
through the reaction all right the
student used data from the study to
generate the graphs below so we're
graphing see the vertical axis we have
absorbance and you could view absorbance
if we if we have a high concentration of
blue food coloring then we're gonna have
a high absorbance and if we have a low
concentration of blue food coloring we'd
have a low absorbence so you could view
this as a as a as a proxy for
concentration of food coloring food
coloring
food coloring concentration
and so here they just plotted absorbance
relative to time here the natural log of
absorbance relative to time here one
over absorbance relevant relative to
time
and so let's look at the questions here
based on the graphs above what is the
order of the reaction with respect to
the blue food coloring with respect to
the food blue food coloring so let's
think let's have a little a super fast
primer so if we're talking about a zero
if we're talking about a zero order
reaction that means that the rate of
reaction is constant
rate
constant and it's independent of
the independent of the concentration of
blue food coloring
independent
pendant
of the concentration i'll just say of
the coloring
concentration of the coloring is that
the case here
well no the rate isn't constant if we
look at just absorbance which is once
again a proxy for our concentration of
food coloring
up here our rate is pretty fast we have
a steep slope over here and then the
stop the slope gets less and less steep
as
as more as our concentration of food
coloring goes down as the reaction
proceeds so this is definitely not a
zero-order reaction if this was a
zero-order reaction when we just plot
absorbance which is once again the proxy
for concentration of food coloring
versus time we would expect to see
something more of a line so if you saw
something like that
then you would say okay
that looks like a zero order reaction
now when we took the natural log of
absorbance which is once again a proxy
for the natural log of the concentration
of food coloring here we get a clear
line
here we actually do
get a clear line and i'm not going to go
into it takes a little bit of calculus
and even a little bit of basic
differential equations to to realize it
but this is a giveaway for a first order
for a first order reaction
so in a first order reaction
in first order
the rate
the rate is proportional
proportional
is proportional
to
the concentration
concentration
let me just write it it's proportional
to the concentration since we're saying
with respect to the blue food coloring
it's proportional to the concentration
of blue food coloring i'll just write
coloring
coloring for short and i'll throw a
little calculus here you could say the
rate of reaction which is the rate and
change of concentration of our coloring
with respect to time
and if this looks completely unfamiliar
to you you've never taken a calculus
class ignore what i'm about to say for
the next
20 seconds this needs to be proportional
to the concentration of coloring
coloring
all right col dot for short and if you
solve this you would see that the
natural log of the concentration of
coloring with respect to if you plot
that versus time is you're going to get
a line so this is a key this is a key
signature of a first order first order
reaction but you can even see it here up
here when the concentration of our
coloring is high our rate is high we
have a steep slope and then when our
concentration becomes lower we also have
our slope being lower so you actually
don't even need calculus you could look
at this one and see that something very
similar to that is happening so this is
a first order reaction if you're
thinking about second order why do they
even show us this well a second order if
you plot one over absorbance versus time
or one over the concentration because as
we said absorbance is a is a proxy for
the concentration of our food coloring
well then this would be a linear plot
but as you can see it is not but if this
is a linear plot then you can say maybe
this is a second order but just to
answer the question this is a first
order reaction
with respect to blue food coloring
all right let's do the part b now
the reaction is known to be first order
with respect to bleach all right so now
we're talking about the reaction order
with respect to bleach not the food
coloring in a second experiment the
student prepares solutions of food
coloring and bleach with concentrations
that differ from those used in the first
experiment all right
when the solutions are combined the
student observes that the reaction
mixture reaches an absorbance near zero
too rapidly
so it's getting to no color too fast in
order to correct the problem the student
proposes the following three possible
modifications to the experiment so the
solution doesn't want the
the student does not want the solution
to become colorless that fast so what
should they do
should they increase the temperature
well increasing the temperature is just
going to make the reaction happen even
faster though the molecules are going to
bump into each other with more energy
and more and and more frequently and so
that's that's just going to make that's
going to get you to colorless even
faster so that's that's going to go in
the opposite direction so we can rule
that out
increasing the concentration of blue
food coloring
or well that that makes sense well they
didn't say blue food growing but i'm
assuming it's blue whatever uh because
well if it's getting clear too fast well
if you add if you add more food coloring
well then it's just gonna it's it's
going to it's going to have a higher
absorbance and it's going to take longer
to get to clear so this one seems
interesting now what about this
increasing the concentration of bleach
well once again the the bleach is the
thing that's that's getting the food is
reacting with the food coloring to make
it clear so if you increase this
concentration you're going to get clear
even faster which is not what the
student wants this is the opposite of
what the student wants so once again we
would cross that one out and the one
that we like is definitely increasing
the concentration of the food coloring
and they say circle the one proposed
modifications let me make sure i'm
circling it i guess i'm more rectangling
it but you get the idea that correct the
problem and explain how that
modification increases the time for the
reaction mixture to reach an absorption
absorbance near zero so i'll write more
coloring
coloring
results
in
higher initial absorption absorbance
higher
initial
initial absorbance
and
and thus
and thus
more time
more
time for
mixture
to reach
to
reach
near
zero
absorbance
word that i really have trouble saying
all right part c
in another experiment a student wishes
to study the oxidation of red food
coloring just in the spirit of that one
i'll underline it with red of red food
coloring with bleach how would the
student need to modify the original
experiment procedure experimental
procedure to determine the order of the
reaction with with respect to the red
food coloring
well overall this is a pretty good
experiment they plotted it in three
different ways which was as we saw a
pretty a very good indicator of what
order of a reaction we were talking
about but at the very beginning of this
question we i talked a little bit about
this wavelength of light this is blue
light and even if you didn't know that
offhand you would say well if we're
studying blue food coloring they
probably picked a wavelength of light
that gets gets absorbed by blue but if
we now
care about red well we would probably
want to use a wavelength of light that
is optimally absorbed by red so
a red wavelength of light which will be
a lower wavelength of light so
change
change the wavelength of light
change
the
wavelength
to
be
suitable
suitable
for absorbance
absorb or absorption
by red coloring
red
coloring or you can see you could lower
the wavelength light or the wavelength
the light should be in the red part of
the spectrum to match the red food
coloring everything else seems
completely reasonable